you just took a timeout to connect with  the creator to those who have not  experienced so that or they've went away  in that connection with the one guys  how's that feeling every time you go to  connect with your creator it's the most  spiritual connection you can have  because you first of all you connected  to your Creator the way you connecting  to your Creator is that you're putting  your forehead to the ground say that I  am nothing nothing I have no ego on you  and that's just I think it's one of  humbling experiences possible that one  of the best forms of Prayer possible  because your humbling yourself where  you're bowing down to the ground nothing  more beautiful than the old days we walk  around like we had this big we had this  big I have this I have this and in  salah/prayer  keep your humble keep it connected with  the crater worship the crater not the  creation my brother pleasure to see you  soon coming up soon on the D show so I'm  Michael